after Disney's death the studio didn't
have the stream of big hits that it used
to I mean it had a big hit every once in
a while but for the most part it never
quite hit the snow-white standards and
on top of that the films were just
taking longer and longer and longer to
make so if the film didn't really wow
audiences people sort of felt it got
gypped and the film that many Disney
fans call the crowning achievement of
failure is the Black Cauldron how bad is
it well for a movie that had a ton of
money put into both the animation and
the advertising it failed to please
audiences and critics alike proving to
be a gigantic financial failure this
film did so bad on its opening weekend
it lost to the Care Bears you heard
right a Disney film lost to the Care
Bears movie it was considered the lowest
point in Disney history so Wow this film
must be really really bad right
well yeah despite the fact that it's
tied to Bro sort of a cult following
it really doesn't hold up that well at
least for my taste what's the story well
it's about this teenage boy who wants to
be a hero the only problem is he's much
more talk and much less due and when I
say talk I mean really talk I mean this
kid doesn't shut up
Dobin doesn't understand I'm not a
little boy anymore I should be doing
heroic deeds for breeding is this to be
my life pampering a pig I'm a warrior
and I know what they're trying to do
they're trying to make it look like he's
full of himself but an innocent and then
when he enters the real world he's gonna
discover things about himself
bla bla bla bla bla but I'm sorry his
voice is annoying and on top of that his
ego is annoying
he barely does anything in this movie
thank you thank you
thank you all but without the help of my
Pig headman here I'm he just praises
himself and God I want to smack him well
anyway he's looking after this pig named
Hedwig who has this very distinct power
of whenever you put her head in a puddle
of water she can see the future isn't
that weird well apparently there's this
evil demon known as the Horned King and
he wants possession of the pig so he can
take her and look into the future to see
if she can lead into the Black Cauldron
what's the Black Cauldron apparently
it's a device that can bring people back
from the dead and create an invincible
army along the way he comes across a
princess yeah imagine a princess into
Disney film and I know I go on and on
about Princess Rance but really there is
absolutely no point to having her be a
princess in this movie even by Disney
standard she doesn't do anything
princessy she doesn't wear fancy dresses
she doesn't give orders she doesn't I
don't know sing we don't even see her
kingdom we don't even see her castle we
don't see anything that Disney loves to
market when it comes to princesses all
she's got going for her is the name so
really there was no reason for it
there's also this really annoying comic
relief that's sort of like a mix between
oatmeal and a hairball yeah you thought
Jar Jar Binks voice was annoying get a
load of this oh poor miserable Kogi de
Jose fierce Maggie's and wagons on his
pony hey yeah between these two
characters voices I want to strangle
this film even the music by the great El
war Bernstein all I hear throughout the
entire thing is ghostbusters listen
tell me that doesn't sound like the Zul
theme okay so for all my bitching and
moaning is this really one of the worst
Disney films of all time well I don't
know if I can go that far
I mean it is annoying but there is some
creativity to the animation well not
much
and as frustrating as it can get it
never gets to a point where it says
anything bad I mean they can't make many
bad messages or morals or anything it's
just our bland and forgettable like a
lot of Disney films that were coming out
at that time it's not the worst but it's
definitely one of the lower ones but
like I said the films really starting to
grow in fans and I find more and more
people actually sir I have this secret
life for it so maybe there is something
there that can grab a certain group of
people but it certainly didn't grab me
and it certainly didn't grab a lot of
audiences at the time Black Cauldron is
often called one of Disney's biggest
failures I think it's just kind of a bad
not the worst but I probably skip